oh là là
c'est le service public
Méline Méline
je peux juste laisser toutes les mêmes
non
vous devez nous réciter le poème de
votre choix
car tu aimes la poésie Hélène demain dès
l'aube à l'heure où blanchit la campagne
je partirai voiture je sais que tu
m'attends Orlando sera là dans la
voiture
j'irai par la montagne je ne peux
demeurer loin de toi plus longtemps sois
sage
je me donne du mal franchement dans ce
seigneur
et tiens-toi plus tranquille tu
réclamais le soir il descend le voici
une atmosphère obscure enveloppe la
ville aux importants la paix aux autres
le souci oh là là c'est le service
public
j'ai pas de mémoire pour les poèmes j'en
ai plus pour les chansons mais il y a
des chansons qui sont des poèmes tu sais
bien
je suis vêtue de froid dans ma peau de
chagrin avec ce cœur de bois qu'on a
jeté au chien ça va donner envie de
m'ouvrir
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu